Houston IV has been a McCaul supporter
from day one in the run-up to the
election she spent months campaigning
for his party putting her job as a
veterinarian on hold now she's once
again hitting the streets of Paris's
momot district this time to convince her
fellow citizens to support the
president's unpopular workplace reforms
I'd be interested to know why you are
unconvinced companies are built on the
backs of their employees and these
people will have fewer rights soon I
don't see the logic why do you say that
no one is going to lose existing rights
Justine is fully committed to the cause
but after the presidential election she
too suffered disappointment
her party chose not to endorse her as a
parliamentary candidate opting for a
more experienced politician to run in
her district Justine tries her best to
come to terms with the decision
Fausta my oh yes that came as a blow
suddenly we didn't see eye to eye
anymore but these rivalries and the
issue of who gets which post they're of
secondary importance even without a seat
in parliament Justine has enough on her
plate the protests against Michael are
growing in number in particular the
left-wing party of jean-luc mélenchon is
drawing support Mellie Shaw is fighting
against macarons plan to legislate his
new workplace agenda by decree without
input from Parliament the government has
launched a full-scale attack on the
French people this affects all of our
society's achievements the education
system the healthcare system pensions
social law this is their attack on us
[Applause]
Justine finds the protests unfair McCaul
made it clear during his election
campaign that he would reform the labor
market by decree as soon as possible and
McCaul was democratically elected that's
why I find these demonstrations unfair
nevertheless recent polls show macarons
popularity has slipped his approval is
even lower than that of his unpopular
predecessor Francois Hollande political
scientists however are taking those
figures with a grain of salt
many of the votes cast in the second
round were not so much formic role as
against the far right candidate marine
lepen that's according to Pascal Paranal
he believes it's only natural that
people grumble but McCrone still has a
few months in which to prove his
abilities macarons political opponents
are at odds and they don't have a clear
leader McCrone strength is partly due to
the weakness of his opponents
at the same time there are signs the
economy is improving so the French are
more likely to feel optimistic about the
future the greater danger according to
peri know is that the young president
Swift rise to power and newfound
celebrity will distance him from his own
base
Justine knows that for this reason
people like her play an important role
the danger now is that there will be
more and more tension that aggression
towards the government will pile up and
divisions will appear that's why it's
important to explain the purpose of the
reforms so that people once again can
identify with these political goals
without supporters like Justine touting
the government's agenda it's possible
the new president's approval ratings
could drop even further